let's go to your voicemail the voicemail
number is two one nine to david p you
can call any time of day but if you call
please don't make logically fallacious
assertions like this caller makes let's
listen to this voicemail and then i'll
break it down for you Davison this is
Randall van der it again and I would
still like to understand your reasoning
behind your hatred of Mel Gibson who
basically in his life has never killed a
single Jew and you're advocating for
this 97 year old Holocaust murderer yeah
you want to get clemency to please
explain to me the difference between
someone that actually was active in one
of the largest mass killings genocide in
the history modern history of you know I
mean how can you just give this man a
free pass cuz he outlived he he avoided
all that for so many years
okay listen let me let me separate these
things for you so what's the call
they're talking about two different
stories we recently had a 97 year old
former Nazi guard a prosecuted and
convicted of war of crimes during the
Holocaust I don't know if technically
they're called war crimes but he was
convicted and at the time there are many
people who were saying this guy's just
too old you shouldn't prosecute the guy
and I said no no if there is no statute
of limitations the fact that he avoided
prosecution his entire life means we
actually should prosecute him you don't
get rewarded because you avoided
prosecution until you were 97 years old
what I did say is you prosecute you
convict if that's what the decision
needs to be and during sentencing you
can consider health in your sentencing
decision that's what I said I did not
suggest granting clemency separately we
had an audience question about what sort
of what sort of political things make it
so that you no longer are a fan of
either an actor celebrity musician
athlete whatever and I explained that
ever since it was revealed that Mel
Gibson is a total vial
anti-semite who went on this crazy rant
when he was pulled over by Los Angeles
police at one point all this stuff I
said the guy disgusts me I can't look at
him I don't watch Mel Gibson's movies do
you see how the two aren't exactly
parallel not watching someone's movies
because they made anti-semitic and
disgusting remarks and talking about the
sentencing for a former SS officer or
some kind of Nazi involved in the
killing of endless numbers of Jews
during World War two you misstated my
positions initially and you're drawing
some kind of false analogy between the
two so please understand what I'm saying
I do make an effort to communicate as
clearly as possible on the show and if
I'm not communicating clearly please let
me know but I didn't suggest clemency
for the Nazi SS guard and I am no in no
way equating Mel Gibson's personal
anti-semitic beliefs to having
perpetrated acts of absolute terror
during World War two
okay I don't know that I can really
explain it any more clearly on the bonus
show today we will talk about Las Vegas
shooting victims struggling to afford
the mounting medical costs of their
treatment we will talk about crazy
Egyptian gay entrapment via an app and
we will also talk about the Kevin Spacey
news about both harassment and a sexual
orientation sort of an interesting story
that I want to discuss on the bonus show
which you get access to two ways number
one david pakman.com slash membership
you will get instant access as a member
to the bonus show number two by becoming
a $5 a month patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show make it happen thanks
for your support we'll talk to you on
the bonus show